to you about price increases come easily
for big businesses but inflation still
squeezes profits The Wall Street Journal
story many big U.S businesses say
they've been able to increase prices
this year with limited pushback from
customers not all the changes are
leading to higher corporate profits
prices are sticky economics like to say
once they go up customers get used to it
and they rarely come down quickly if
companies cost and fall they can pass
along a little of the savings and keep
the rest customers get a bit of a break
and margins still widen corporate profit
margins the difference between expenses
and revenue reached historical high
levels in recent quarters helped by
strong consumer demand for range of
goods and services
so what does this mean customers are not
complaining that prices are going up but
how long is that sustainable time I
don't know because you know what's the
one number that they keep bragging about
that hasn't changed and when that
changes it's a massive massive collapse
you know what it is unemployment yeah
yep Employment Number still at two and a
half percent strong unemployment numbers
are strong unemployment numbers are
strong you know everybody plays games
with headlines yeah what if this was the
headline America had to read Jerome
Powell will continue raising rates until
inflation drops 75 everybody would be
like holy crap it has to drop 75 that's
do you see what I mean do you know how
long exactly that's gonna take two years
Tom I agree I I think I think at the
earliest it's 18 months at the latest is
30 months this could go into 2024 is
what it could go into I I think it will
I think the presidential election in
2024 is the defining moment not the
midterm election right here because
people haven't seen the bottom yet I
think the biggest spike in the history
of stock market single day Spike going
up will be the day after election in
2024. you're going to see it is going to
be the biggest bone to the roof you've
ever seen if again I'm purely if if the
Republicans it's not an if okay it's a
[ __ ] show in America and it ain't
changing it's not an if it's just who is
it going to be a DeSantis is it going to
be a whoever it it's not about it if
like look at the way they pinned covet
on Trump covet doesn't happen Trump's
the president today everybody says that
on the left or right the middle Bill
Maher Bill Maher says that yeah covet
doesn't happen Trump's the president
today okay
um
what's been worse than a Biden
Administration in the last 40 years what
does America typically do when they have
a site politically that when the economy
is bad and everybody's struggling
everybody says what we have to change
the way we're voting because the people
in the let in the middle say what I'm
not doing this again
the day after 2024 election is done with
and it's announced watch what the single
day matter of fact make a note of when
we said this
watch what happens today after election
everybody on the market is going to say
the single biggest uptick in the history
the stock market a single day is going
to be said the day after election in
2024. mark my words wow and that's going
to go to 50 000 and 2024 2025 20 25
000. that will go to 20. that will go to
50 000 in 2025 2026 remember when I said
this to you I'm okay being wrong and
there's a 80 90 chance I want to be
wrong but I'm telling you that in my
opinion I'm not telling you to do this
talk to your experts talk to your
account or talk to your advisors
I'm banking on Dow's gonna be 50
000 20 25 20 26. wow but it's going to
be a [ __ ] showing 2022 2023. and people
can talk about do I like my politicians
do I like my president all you want but
let me tell you Jimmy Carter never had a
sex scandal Jimmy Carter never had a you
know the profane moment off Mike Jimmy
Carter was a remarkably nice man who has
been proved he spent the last 42 years
he's 98 years old and he's still with us
and he's still doing charitable service
right
um and he makes a headline when he falls
down to a charitable service and gets
hurt and he gets back up he was a nice
guy he was a guy that didn't have a lot
of like ooh about him right but he was
fired by the American people in a 49
State Landslide so let's by Reagan
Reagan excuse me Reagan beat Mondale in
the 49th state Landslide but it was um
he was fired in a monstrous Landslide
simply because the account economy sucks
I'm hurting you're fired and what you're
about to see in 2024 is four times worse
yeah I think there I keep thinking about
issues too because with all of this
stuff that feels very tangible to people
you know gas prices prices of goods and
services you feel that every day you
can't convince people that that's not
happening because they feel it so what
is the Biden let's say Biden runs again
he's not going to run again let's say
Kamala Harris I call her cackling Harris
steps up to the plate and she she
decides she's going to be the person
what is their issue is their only place
of urban moms and talking about abortion
because honestly I really don't think
that that can become a key issue when
people can't afford to put food on the
table I just don't see how these social
issues that they intend to play can play
well for them they can't play economic
issues because they've been in charge
for how long and the whole economy is in
massive distress is it a distraction do
they want chaos do they want us involved
in some mess with Ukraine so that they
can blame outside forces for what's
going on in here instead of taking
personal response possibility for the
horrific policies that they put into
place I don't know I just as the days go
on I do think Republicans will have a
big victory both in the midterms and in
the next presidential election I don't
particularly think it matters who runs
because this is so bad that people will
choose whatever that is but I'm curious
what the campaign from the left will
look like because I don't see a plus I I
keep searching for it with the exception
of them saying to Suburban moms they're
going to take you know abortion rights
away they want to bring women back you
know several decades I just don't see
that as being a powerful message given
what the state of the economy looks like
today you're going to watch this a lot
do you think in their Echo chamber
though that they're going to go with
that personal Liberty message you know
abortion how can they go all the Liberty
messes they just wanted everyone to get
forced vaccination or lose their job
I'm asking you because your fingers on
the pulse of stuff more than mine is so
I'm asking an honest question what do
you think do you think in their Echo
chamber they're just going to go for
personal Liberties personal freedom
since saying that the Republicans are
going to repress you and I think they're
going to go for the female the Suburban
mom vote I think they're going to go for
women and I think they're going to hope
that it's Donald Trump because they can
use his past as something to go against
they can't go against his policy they'll
use his past they'll paint him out to be
a bad guy they'll bring back you know
sexual allegations they'll bring about
threat they're hoping for Trump because
they also you'll notice every speech
recently Joe Biden did that speech where
he looked angry it looked like he was
standing at the gates of hell I don't
know who who advised him to do that it
was absolute but you'll notice he didn't
talk about the present much what he
talked about was you know the capital he
talked about what happened they need to
go backward and blame Trump or they have
nothing which is why I keep saying if
it's not Trump I think it's advantageous
to the right so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]